alors comment la gauche peut-elle
rassemblé une primaire une bonne une
mauvaise idée la gauche at-elle encore
une chance pour la présidentielle de
2000 22 on attend vos réactions sur
télégramme tout de suite placé des bars
[Musique]
et sur ses plateaux eric revel
éditorialiste politique bonsoir vous
êtes accompagné de renier brunet guy
bonsoir vous êtes membre de l'équipe de
campagne d'arnaud montebourg et donc de
la remonte à la de la france et puis on
skype avec nous guillaume kashi
porte-parole de fabien roussel candidat
du parti communiste français à la
présidentielle et directeur également de
publication de la revue cause commune
bonsoir à tous et merci d'être avec nous
renier brunet guy arnaud montebourg
avait appelé avant l'année d'alcoa à
l'union l'a vu avec emilie google force
est de constater que pour l'instant
cette union ça a pas l'air de prendre en
tous les cas est la fille élevée et pcf
n'en veulent pas est-ce que l'union est
ce qu'elle est toujours possible anne
hidalgo ce soir elle a dit ça ce soir
s'il ya pas de rassemblement de la
gauche il n'y a pas de gauche au second
tour c'est vrai c'est vrai l'enterrement
raison je ne vois pas aujourd'hui
comment la gauche peut gagner étant
autant divisée et je crois aussi que
pour les primaires en tout cas la
proposition lindahl gohelle mérite
d'exister d'être porte dans le débat
public est là c'en est une mais en tout
cas c'est pas celle que privilégie
aujourd'hui on le sait que organiser une
primaire saint dans un laps de temps
aussi court sa part est déjà prêt à m'en
extrêmement compliqué et qu'aujourd'hui
avant de choisir une personne il faut se
mettre d'accord sur un programme commun
aujourd'hui on le voit ya des points de
convergence des points de divergence il
faut se mettre autour de la table et
négocier tout simplement il faut
négocier ce qui est possible ensemble
négocier les points de divergence et
ensuite on choisira un candidat
potentiel la semaine autour de la table
ça tombe bien puisque les sommes cachées
et là également il n'est pas
physiquement la haute mais il est quand
même là guillaume catchy et donc fabien
roussel ce matin sur france info hésité
à employer le mot non
pour dit-il dire oui aux français et
pour être
le président de tous les français et
pour rassembler mais comment rassembler
quand il n'est crédité que de 2% des
intentions de vote et deux ans et demi
pour cent pour arnaud montebourg
en fait si vous voulez ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que nous avons proposé nous
un pacte d'engagement commun depuis le
départ notamment en vue des élections
législatives qui permettent davantage le
rassemblement et puis en rappelant que
les élections législatives sont les
élections déterminantes si vous voulez
dans le cadre même dans le cadre de la
5ème république avec par le monde a
baissé pour l'instant on voudrait me
faire chier vendre passe à la troisième
mi temps il ya quand même le premier
tour et le deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle qui sont véritablement
comme le premier match avant de penser
au deuxième
j'entends bien mais en l'occurrence pour
ce qui est des élections présidentielles
vous voyez bien une difficulté pourquoi
la gauche aussi faible c'est pas parce
qu'elle est divisée elle est si faible
parce que bien une partie notre pays n'a
pas confiance en elle et on comprend
pourquoi parce que l'expérience qui a
rassemblé les socialistes et des
écologistes sa tanière fois a été
désastreuse regardez l'extrême droite
par exemple extrême droite ils ont
quatre candidats à l'élection
présidentielle ça les empêche pas de
faire des scores tout à fait
considérable donc je pense c'est une
réponse qui n'est pas à la hauteur des
problèmes les la réponse que la gauche
tout apporté c'est de répondre aux
préoccupations des français est
aujourd'hui eh bien on voit bien que tu
rassembles de questions importantes et
notamment le rapport il ya en traités
européens non et ça on devrait être
d'accord avec le corps dit le
représentant de l'équipe de thé dans le
monde bourg on voit bien que c'est pas
en continuant à remettre une pièce dans
ce juke box tas on réussira à mobiliser
eric revel quand on comptabilise tous
les candidats de la gauche on arrive
selon les derniers sondages à 25%
environ comment est-ce que cesse
expliquer ce que c'est une désaffection
des français pour les de l'idée au
gauche d'abord il n'ya pas une gauche
mais il ya plusieurs gauches donc
rassemblé plusieurs gauches sous une
même bannière c'est déjà la cua nature
du cercle belval salue cette formule les
gauches irréconciliables mais c'est vrai
que quand on écoute le représentant du
parti communiste sur présentant d'arnaud
montebourg les représentants ou anne
hidalgo on voit bien qu'ils sont pas du
tout sur la même longueur d'onde mais au
delà du rassemblement à l'époque il
avait la gauche plurielle quand il
boxait le programme commun alors ça
c'est pas d'une modernité absolue parce
que à l'époque les communistes faisait
équipe avec françois mitterrand georges
marchais robert fabre et on voit ce que
ça a permis aux communistes de la
manière dont qui se sont effondrés
d'ailleurs après le programme commun de
80 83 mais j'aimerais dire une chose
c'est qu'aujourd'hui au delà de la
question du rassemblement il ya quelque
chose de beaucoup plus central pourquoi
est-ce que l'électorat populaire a fui
le parti communiste pour leur assemblée
nationale pourquoi est ce que les
françaises et les français
majoritairement on verra les résultats
d'élections ne croient plus en la gauche
mais en fait parce que la gauche a porté
pendant des années des années et des
années dans les années 80 90 des idées
sociétal qui modifiait l'évolution la
société française et que depuis ces
années 90 la gauche est en panne d'idées
elle ne propose plus aux classes les
plus défavorisées elle ne parle plus
assez classe là et aujourd'hui je le
disais tout à l'heure vous avez l'effet
inverse la gauche proposé des idées dans
les années 90 et en réaction la droite
réagissait aux idées de la gauche et
donc les réactionnaires c'étaient les
jambes droites et bien si je force un
peu le trait dirait qu'il se passe
exactement le contraire aujourd'hui
c'est que ce sont les idées de droite ou
de droite nationale qui sont sur le
sommet de la table et la gauche est en
réaction aux idées qui sont sur la table
et qui font le débat politique c'est sa
toute la faillite de la gauche
aujourd'hui et je pousse un peu plus la
caricature et jeudi comme la gauche est
en réaction aux idées qui qui qui
aujourd'hui sont en débat dans le sur la
présidentielle les nouveaux
réactionnaires ce sont les gens de
gauche en réalité parce qu'ils n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de réagir aux
idées qui sont portées par la droite et
ses salles à versements il ne parle plus
aux classes populaires je vous propose
de réagir messieurs à ce qu'a écrit
pasquet des sur le compte arte france de
télégrammes la gauche existe toujours ce
sont les politiciens étant reconnu comme
étant de gauche par le peuple de gauche
qui n'existe plus vos réactions je
commence avec avec vous guillaume cacher
ou à l'egypte après un 2e 2e par là
guillaume
givet allez-y la gauche à mes yeux oui
existe toujours sauf que quand vous
voyez par exemple
en effet il ya plusieurs gauches ça
c'est clair on le voit et c'est
difficile de se mettre tout le monde met
tout le monde d'accord autour de la
table il faut le faire je crois il faut
le faire et on a des points de
convergence certains entre les
différentes personnes entre les
différents candidats en tout cas mais
aujourd'hui on parle toute divergence à
chaque fois on dit je ne suis pas
d'accord sur ceux ci une super accord
sur cela mettons d'abord de convergence
ensemble et ensuite on verra ce qu'on
peut faire je crois une chose comme qui
est extrêmement importante c'est
qu'avant même de parler
d'autres sujets de personnes il faut
qu'on montre probable des points de
convergence entre nous et on doit
rassembler en tout cas cette gauche là
ça c'est clair on est obligé de le faire
et après peut-être que on verra le
résultat ensuite mais en tout cas un
objet de commencer par là d'avoir
comment dire une candidature moins de
candidatures en tout cas à gauche ça
c'est clair guillaume cachiez renier
brunet gay vous a tendu la main vous
l'apprenez
c'est pas s'il tend la main en tout cas
moi je suis d'accord pour tendre la main
pour prendre le chemin à une autre
occasion peut-être mais pas sur la
question des primaires parce que comme
ça comme comme fabien roussel ce matin
je ne vais pas dire non il vous dit pas
non vous dites un nom un petit peu
pour la balance d'arnaud montebourg en
disant on est prêt à se retirer ce n'est
pas en disant on se rejoignent et nous
comme trop souvent on entend ce en
disant ok on met le toit nature en
retrait reparlons de nos convergences et
ensuite loué la force à force de dire
tout le temps ça est ça qui sera le
principal responsable de la division
non mais écoutez il faut qu'on arrête de
parler de ce titre de division
permanence comme si l'union avait une
capacité propulsive aujourd'hui des gens
qui cherchent déco et relancé des
réponses à leurs problèmes qui ont fait
une espèce de bloody volga et un truc
politiciens qui se voit comme le nez au
milieu de la figure avec des gens qui ne
pensent pas la même chose en disant voté
pour nous et vous verrez bien ce que ça
donne ça ne donnera rien ça n'est pas
possible la politique ce n'est pas cela
et puis excusez moi essayons de nous
rappeler au moment du front populaire
c'est quoi le front populaire tu es un
moment où effectivement l'extrême droite
est très forte et qu'est ce qu'on fait
eh bien il ya des rats franchement mais
au premier tour chacun se présenter au
deuxième tour on soutient celui qui est
le mieux placé et en même temps on
avance avec les pommes une campagne
politique aux décharges encore
faudrait-il en design colosse qui
puissent accéder au deuxième tour et
pour le moment c'est pas le cas
j'entends bien mais c'est pas en mettant
des genres c'est pas en mettant ensemble
des gens sur le champ sans contenu très
arrêtées qu'on réussira sa nasa n'aura
pas de côté propulsif n'aura pas de côté
pour attirer des gens aujourd'hui ce que
l'on dit c'est déjà mettons nous autour
de la table tout simplement déjà
d'historique négocier ça pour rien qui
en sortira il ya un site qui s'appelle
l'abri mais requiert une association qui
veut créer une primaire qui pour
l'instant n'existe pas est ce que vous
seriez prêt à y participer
alors ça je laisse le candidat y
répondre en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est qu'aujourd'hui une primaire on
n'est pas forcément favorable à cela
aujourd'hui avant même de parler de
choix de personnes il faut parler déjà
de convergence de programme il s'est
juste au final de dire on choisit
quelqu'un avec un programme qui est
préétabli menti mais pas d'accord à la
fin on sait que ça ne marche pas arnaud
montebourg a été le premier à proposer
les boeufs les primaires en france en
tout cas il a écrit un rapport sur le
sujet en 2009
il a été précurseur il a entre
guillemets poussé à ceux appliqués en
france aujourd'hui on voit les limites
de l'exercice dans un régime qui est
entre guillemets tripartite ça marche
bien à la gym qui est bi partie
aujourd'hui les limites de l'exercice
aujourd'hui en france en tout cas et
d'un prenons-en acts a le mérite
d'exister les primaires c'est pas le
meilleur en tout cas maintenant on est
prêt à étudier tout ce qui est possible
non en tout cas étudions parle on
échange on et ça se trouve il y aura
cinq candidatures à gauche à la fin en
avril peut-être on n'en sait rien mais
en tout cas mettons nous d'accord avant
et discutons est ce qu'il pourrait y
avoir une candidature le santo bira et
oui j'allais vous en parler pour une
raison très simple lorsque vient juste
juste avant eric revel juste un mode
anne hidalgo qui a parlé injustement ce
soir de madame taubira en disant j'ai
beaucoup d'amitié pour elle mais j'ai
encore pas parler avec elle voilà il ya
les très bien parfait franchement j'ai
pas comment déployer un jeu j'essaie de
raisonner un peu froidement 1 évidemment
je ne prends pas parti j'essaie d'avoir
une vision un peu global bon je
comprends très bien le besoin de
programmes avant de se mettre d'accord
sur des noms tout ça est très juste et
d'ailleurs c'est l'honneur de la
politique de proposer aux électeurs des
programmes sur lequel ils vont voter
plutôt que qu'une incarnation forte ou
pas mais je vous ferai remarquer une
chose c'est que le point commun de cette
campagne présidentielle me semble-t-il
que ce soit à gauche ou à droite ou chez
les écologistes
la vraie nouveauté c'est la radicalité
c'est le mot a dit call à droite je fais
pas de dessin la radicalité elle
s'affichait les hôtes dans les sondages
chez les verts madame rousseau a failli
l'emporter alors qu'elle est arrivé de
nulle part sur un programme certes mais
sur un positionnement
radical pour les écologistes alors moi
je dis aux gens de gauche qui
réfléchissent ensemble
cher arnaud montebourg chez monsieur
roussel chez madame hidalgo essayer de
trouver un démineur dénominateur chez
vous qui incarnerait aux yeux des
français du peuple de gauche la
radicalité et j'envoie une justement
j'en voyais qui s'appelle madame taubira
parce que précisément madame taubira
elle ferait plaisir au parti communiste
en piquant des voix à jean luc mélenchon
ce qui déplairait pas la place du
colonel fabien arnaud montebourg je
pense il a de bonnes relations avec
madame toby à madame hidalgo la connais
depuis longtemps elle a peut incarner
cette radicalité aujourd'hui je pense
qu'au delà du programme il faut un
candidat de gauche qui incarne une
radicalité à gauche si c'est quelque
chose d'un peu un peu un peu mou un peu
tiède et bien ça ne prendra pas quel que
soit le programme donc peut-être que
madame taubira oui justement peut-être
que madame taubira qui d'ailleurs dit un
peu partout qu'elle réfléchisse
éventuellement une candidature pourrait
incarner pour la gauche cette radicalité
et et je pense que pour jean luc
mélenchon ce serait sans doute la pire
des nouvelles que d'avoir une candidate
comme cela qu'ils incarneraient la
gauche alors pas le parti communiste
mais qui incarnerait le parti socialiste
parce qu'elle pourrait ratisser assez
large dans son camp évidemment il s'agit
pas de dire qu'on ait au beer à sera au
second tour il serait il serait il
s'agirait de dire que madame taubira et
éviterait peut-être une taque magistrats
la gauche en affichant en plus haute et
plus sain mais en affichant un score
raisonnable a régné brunet guinée est ce
que vous vous ralliez rayé du côté des
rois mental avec arnaud montebourg à
christiane taubira écoutez il faut
échanger il faut il faut discuter je
n'en sais rien en tout cas de ce qui est
sur la table aujourd'hui on n'a pas
échangé récemment et que madame taubira
ça fait quelques mois il me semble
qu'elle réfléchit à cette possibilité
écoutez discutons-en moment venu avec
toutes les personnes qui souhaitent
construire un programme ensemble à
gauche même question pour voguer à me
cacher
nous on n'est pas dans l'idée de se
retirer vis-à-vis de madame taubira dans
la mesure où de borély date et nous bien
sûr c'est une personnalité de gauche que
nous aimons n'est pas une position
sectaire évidemment ce qu'est la fed en
matière de mariage pour tous et pour
nous quelque chose de très positif et
donc il n'y a pas de problème mais en
revanche quel est son programme en
matière économique et sociale on peut
pas se rallier comme ça une personnalité
juste parce qu'on aime bien et par les
actes manqués la pub n'est autre que
ministre de la justice
une j'aimerais vous montrer une réaction
de bénéfique sur sur télégramme les
partis ne servent qu'à diviser les
français ils sont pseudo sur la pseudo
opposition et la crise actuelle l'a
démontré la gauche comme la droite
sur définitivement morte est ce que vous
comprenez les téléspectateurs qui m'en
fous je pense que on a besoin au
contraire on a besoin d'un affrontement
démocratique gauche droite dans ce pays
on a cru pouvoir s'en passer en tout cas
les français qui ont voté pour emmanuel
macron ont cru pouvoir s'en passer avec
le en même temps moi je prétends qu'au
contraire il faut de vraies lignes de
fracture politique il faut opposer des
programmes il faut débattre
démocratiquement
de rassembler la gauche mais quand on
rassemble forcément à faire des
consensus mais moi je moi je parle de
gauche républicaine et de droite
républicaine je pense que ce clivage qui
a beaucoup déçus eux aussi les français
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont tournés vers
d'autres partis mais ce clivage là entre
une gauche héritière de jaurès du front
populaire et une droite républicaine
plus gaulliste autre chose c'est
extrêmement important pour le pays
surtout dans le contexte qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui de de violences et
d'affrontements bon je ne sais pas si
emmanuel macron sera réélu évidemment
s'il sera au second tour et que ça mais
je pense que la disparition de ce
clivage qui était quand même le moteur
principal la démocratie française
pendant des décennies il faut absolument
pas qu'on le conte le pont le conte le
gone qu'on le raye il faut absolument
pas que les partis traditionnels
disparaissent au profit de trucs qui
représente pas grand chose finalement
parce qu'on a besoin dans un pays
démocratique
d'affrontements idéologiques de débat
projet contre projet plus que l'individu
si on l'a pas eh bien on est dans cette
pièce de situations où la violence ne
cesse de monter parce que précisément il
ya plus d'exutoire politique le en même
temps c'est pas c'est pas un driver
politique c'est une posture marketing
c'est bon pour le représentant de la
start up nation mais c'est pas ça qui
structurent un débat démocratique parce
que vous êtes la médiation entièrement
d'accord
quand on regarde la gauche morcelée est
ce qu'au final ce ne sont pas les égaux
des candidats qui prennent le pas sur
les idéologies en elle-même montebourg a
pas d'ego ça se saurait vous êtes dur
non non là il a un peu il a il a quand
même de lego comme tout à chacun
néanmoins néanmoins aujourd'hui
il a mis sa correction dans la balance
c'est le premier à le faire voilà en
disant très clairement il est prêt à se
retirer pour quelque chose pour un
projet commun donc donc on fait le
premier pas on tend une main par contre
s'il n'ya rien s'il n'y a personne
comment dire qu'ils souhaitent
construire ensemble eh bien on ira et on
ira jusqu'au bout c'est simple que cela
voilà et je reviens en tout cas sur les
propos de monsieur je crois qu'en effet
on a besoin d'affrontements idéologiques
il faut échanger il faut débattre entre
gauche droite on peut débattre aussi
l'intérieur de la gauche si ses seins en
tout cas et il faut 7 c'est ce débat
pour être une forme de soupape de
sécurité en tout cas dans le débat
public mais regardez comment regarder
comment fabien roussel j'aimerais
peut-être voir votre votre point de vue
comment fabien roussel s'est décalé sur
sa droite en matière de sécurité
en france est absolument vers femmes
samassa m'a frappé c'est à dire qu'avant
le parti communiste était plus du côté
du peuple guillaume cacher un
championnat il va pas être d'accord mais
moi je salue des déclarations de
monsieur roussel joue j'étais
extrêmement étonné de voir devoir de
voir le parti communiste prendre cet axe
là je ne le comptage pas du tout rires
je constate game cash et non non non non
parce que justement pourquoi est ce que
la gauche on est là aujourd'hui mais
peut-être aussi parce que à un moment
elle a commencé à renoncer à s'occuper
des préoccupations populaires et parmi
les préoccupations populaires et
notamment dans les milieux populaires il
faut bien le dire et vous savez contre
qui tu étais pas et quand même on a le
départeme parce que le rassemblement
national avait avait mis la main sur ce
thème donc tous les paris perd ça suffit
mais oui bien sage et ça c'est assez
serré du drap d'or les excuses
j'aimerais que vous répondiez après à ma
question également sur le fait est ce
que les égos prennent le pas sur
l'idéologie
quand aucun candidat ne saurait être
retiré sa candidature et qu'au final
voilà 25% réunir une chose très je vais
vous répondre mais juste ont ils doivent
descendre aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de loi de 1905 la laïcité
un moment elle a été kidnappée par le
front national kidnappé est absolument
dévoyé et bien non nous le disons ça
suffit ce hold-up lamentable les vrais
défenseurs de la laïcité c'est bien sûr
une valeur de jaurès et les valeurs de
la gauche et nous nous portons
aujourd'hui cette valeur tant pis si les
autres et bien on en faire un kidnapping
lamentable sur la question des ego je
dois reconnaître que moi ça m'insupporte
parce que c'est vraiment pas une
question d'ego qu'est ce que c'est que
ce soit une question de débat politique
iliad y ait des projets pour la france
qui ne sont pas les mêmes ça n'a rien à
voir avec des égos des uns et des autres
qu'est ce qu'on va faire en matière
économique aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on va
relever le pays en se donnant sur dotant
des moyens est ce qu'on va par exemple
nationaliser la société générale lâche
analyse et axa pour pouvoir donner à
l'état les moyens d'intervenir pour
répondre aux besoins des français et
relancer le pays sur des questions
importantes voilà ça n'a rien à voir
avec des questions d'ego quel projet ont
nourri pour l'éducation nationale est-ce
qu'on va recruter des dizaines de
milliers d'enseignants par rapport à ça
où est ce qu'on va laisser filer pour
l'europe parce qu'on va aller vers
l'europe fédérale où est ce qu'on va
travailler au développement d'une
souveraineté populaire bon voilà c'est
des questions qui n'ont rien à voir avec
de dégoût
de la question des ego c'est aussi une
question d'argent parce que si vous
n'avez pas de candidats qui se
présentent derrière vous avez du mal à
avoir des députés et si vous n'avez pas
de députés derrière vous avez du mal à
alimenter la caisse de votre parti il ya
aussi cette question là et chacun diallo
ne touche pas au grisbi parce que c'est
aussi une question d'argent il faut
financer les partis politiques
il ya une aide de l'état mais il ya
aussi ce que les députés reverse à
chacun de leur parti si vous n'êtes pas
de candidat bas c'est compliqué d'avoir
des députés et c'est le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup et eric revel d'avoir
répondu à nos questions merci à vous
deux guillaume cachiez d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
par parole de fabien roussel candidat
pcf à la présidentielle et directeur de
publication de la revue cause commune
merci également à vous régnez à brunet
guillet vous êtes membre de l'équipe de
campagne d'arnaud montebourg et de la
roma cla